we have breaking news from France where
chef author and TV host Anthony Bourdain
died by suicide overnight
that's according to CNN where Bourdain
had a travel and Food Programme for
several years ordained who was 61 was
found dead in a hotel room he built a
solid career in New York City
restaurants before turning to television
where he won a Peabody Award and many
other honors Cordain told Anthony Mason
in 2016 that his later life changed him
I think when you travel as much as I
have you I don't want to say I'm more
humble but I think you become aware of
how other people live how hard their
lives are how big the world is and then
of course the fatherhood changes
everything and I became a father at 50
and you know at that moment you stopped
being the star of the film that's the
truth that's for me that was an enormous
relief and a gift CNN says in a
statement this morning his love of great
adventure new friends find food and
drink and the remarkable stories of the
world made him a unique storyteller his
talents never cease to amaze us and we
will miss him very much
our thoughts and prayers are with his
daughter and family at this incredibly
difficult time